the US Embassy is being moved from Tel
Aviv to Jerusalem on orders of the
president it opens on Monday inside an
existing consulate building until a
permanent home is built here to discuss
the move and reaction in Time magazine
is editor-at-large Carl vid Carl good
morning you spend a lot of time there
you've been covering this a lot
intensely can you talk to us about why
this is so contentious to recognize this
area as a capital Jerusalem well it's
it's not only like the area of what the
Israel now exists in physically that's
contended it's a matter of contention
that the war was fought over 1948 but
it's also the idea of a capital
Jerusalem's been a disputed city for
most of its existence but the dispute
now is between Israel and the
Palestinian people and if you couldn't
have a two-state solution both states
have to have a capital the whole idea
was always that they would share
Jerusalem Trump is saying it belongs to
Israel this this is a symbolic move at
the moment because the embassy is for
practical purposes most of the staff is
still going to be still in Tel Aviv but
they're but but they're saying now that
Jerusalem is officially the embassy so
it's symbolic but it's substantial it is
substantial because you're basically
telling the Palestinians you're gonna
have to find somewhere else yeah I'll
call your capital
so it really undercuts the idea of a
two-state solution which has been in
trouble for a long time anyway really
interesting this this consulate building
in Jerusalem it's located in South
Jerusalem some of it sort of a lapse
into what was what was considered
Palestinian territory before 1967 but it
also was like sort of was staffed by
Palestinians serve Palestinian East
Jerusalem as well as is is Israeli Jews
and from West Jerusalem and it was kind
of an empowerment zone for the
Palestinians you can see them serving or
or receiving the supplications and
applications of ideological Israeli Jews
and speaking of the Palestinians the
Palestinian President Mahmoud Abbas
called the embassy relocation a slap in
the face even saying that Washington
could no longer be regarded as an honest
broker where does it stand I mean it
just seems like we continue to talk
about these two groups assignations
and now it's a slap in the face that
according to the Palestinian president
the idea was always that the US could
could be the broker could take the
interests of the Palestinians and
balance them because against the
interests of Israel the idea being that
both sides could trust and and this is
what a boss is saying is like and he was
put in place in some ways by the
Americans not a militant man always a
peacemaker and he was never able to
deliver because his real wouldn't
wouldn't negotiate in good faith
according to the Palestinians but it
point is it hasn't happened and although
these 24 so where does this leave peace
efforts then where they've been but but
but even worse and and they haven't been
in a good place how's this being
received by by other Arabs other Arab
countries in a much more muted way than
people would have expected if this had
happened 10 years ago when there was
still more hope for peace you know and
where Israel wasn't as entrenched and
hadn't had the alignments that it has
with the with the Saudis and and other
Gulf states you would have seen much
more of an outcry from the Arab world
Carl Vick thanks so much